(Clapping)
We had so much fun with you
yesterday.
I had such a good time.
So, you notice, I wore my flower in honor of you
Yes
And then Tyler Perry texted
something about how he hated it.
Yes (Laughter)
He hated the flower.
He thought it looked like a big orange wound.
And I said, I did it, you know, for you.
So I called him when I got off the air and I said
"Drew really wants you to come on the show."
You'd really do?
I really do
That's what I said, I said
she really wants you to come on the show
even though you insulted our flowers
Yes
He said, "I'm sick of doing zooms."
I think we're all zoomed out.
He goes, "I will come when I can be in the studio."
Great. And we will wait.
So I'm thinking
So what I, what I think is so great too.
I said, you know, as it turns out
Drew and I are in the same building, different places
so you can do us and you can do Drew on the same day
I believe they call it a twofer.
believe they call it a twofer.
Yes, I love it!
(Clapping)
You know, one of the things that was so
bizarre about launching with no gas
and no audiences is I like to lean into comedy.
You know, I know you have a boundary of like
when it gets too silly and you get to sit
down with so many people and have in-depth interviews.
I love having a conversation.
I know, but you're very good at it.
But I think what you did is so brave.
Number one, congrats on being picked up for season two.
that is so hard.
I get to stay, I get to stay with this crew.
That is so hard. The crew is always the best.
We always listen, we can't do I without them.
We're all we've had.
But Drew, this is hard.
This is very hard.
Every day, you have a great show and then you think, okay
now I gotta come up with another one.
Now I gotta come up with another one and another one.
And I really took all of your words of wisdom at
the beginning, when we started talking and you
said something to me that I hooked into so much
and it has been a bit of my North star
What?
Which is, you said
"There will never not be stories."
Yes, to me.
We never have a boring day.
Even when it's a slow news day
there's always something to talk about.
And you must feel that too.
I...
You clearly like the news.
I love the news.
And I found myself as a producer and a director
battling the same things
which is, how do you pull off all of these different tones?
How do you have a serious conversation
with someone and then do a stand for stains and
and express yourself and be comedic?
How does you know
I look at that as life though, Drew
that's sort of life, that's what we do.
The thing that excites me so much
about Oprah Daily is
I do believe it is life.
I think you are a hundred percent accurate.
And I think when people are trying to do everything
from deal with emotions, to want to put something out there
into the world, it is a mood board.
It is many different tones and colors.
You know, the Oprah magazine had been a huge success.
We were there for 20 years.
Imagine 20 years, we were a monthly magazine
and Oprah decided she's, you know, reading the room.
And she said, "You always want to leave
before they ask you to leave."
You know, even our talk show was 25 years.
She was number one the whole time.
She was probably the only one that was ready to leave
because the staff wasn't the audience wasn't.
But she said, "I just feel it's time."
So with a magazine, we have, you know, it was
a monthly print edition.
She said, "I really want to take advantage of digital."
So now she said the magazine's not ending, it's evolving.
And that's what it is.
This is an evolution of O, The Oprah Magazine.
We're calling it Oprah daily.
So you can get it every day online.
And we're going to do four print issues.
And we've got an Oprah insiders for people that really
want to go into Oprah land.
And I'm very, very proud of it.
It launched a week ago today, and then we've got tonight.
Can I talk about OG Chronicles?
Please, I cannot wait.
It's tonight.
OG Chronicles, Oprah and I live.
Seven o'clock East coast time, OG Chronicles
a special edition live
where, you know, people
were going to, you can zoom, you can log on and
sign up to join us tonight at seven o'clock
I'm really looking forward to it.
You know what O G stands for an O G Chronicles?
Original gangster?
Oprah and Gail
Oh my gosh
(Laughter)
(Upbeat music)
(Music fades)